Let's build a little bit of context here.
So this session is we are trying to
show how to take a Laravel application
from your local machine, produce a container based
development environment using Docker and Docker Compose,
and show you the real kind of day
one deploy to Kubernetes scenario.
Anyway, it's it's really frustrating,
actually.
It's not a nice developer experience. It's not
really a way to make it nicer. It's
just
Yeah. It's just painful. You
need package lock as well, I think, depending
if they're using it.
I'm gonna ignore that fail forever.
I don't think we should commit lock fails.
Oh, yeah.
Yeah. That's I mean, we have containers. We
already have immutability.
We have repeatability.
We have all of this stuff. It's like
the lock fail.
Like, your deployment without containers makes sense, but
I'm
I think we have enough.
Don't wanna get too cocky, but I think
it looks good.
What's it doing there? Upbuilding.
Alright. So let's assume this works. Right? Of
course.
So you're let me clarify what you're saying
there. Is you believe the problem that this
is failing is because it's missing access
dumping?
Right. Or let's let's actually read the message.
Ah. Slash public.
Root fail system public CSS app CSS.
Not slash node slash public.
So that's our issue.
Why?
So we it has to be a fail.
It works when we change the mode to
be a dot.
Yeah.
That's the bet that's really bugging me. We're
we're good developers. Right? David David, look in
the chat.
Has some has this person saved us? They're
anonymous.
No.
I would be very disappointed
if Maxi's
wrapper
around webpack required
Artisan to exist, which means
you're probably right.
But maybe it uses the Artisan file
the presence of the Artisan file for some
sort of
directory
relativeness to to find the root. Do know
what I mean?
At least the show notes for this episode
will be really easy. Like, watch Kieran struggle.
What did Kieran and David struggle for forty
minutes? I can't believe that worked.
Yeah. Why? Why?